Chris Waters here with the Gamespot news
update just a few weeks ahead of
Destiny's first paid DLC releasing the
opening cinematic has released online
and it's pretty awesome the trailer is
narrated by a woman named Aris who's
talking about the hive leader croa The
Raid boss of the new DLC it's the first
proper cinematic for Destiny besides
that short really brief irrelevant video
that plays when you start a new game the
video was posted by Mr Jester 6598 who
wrote in the description I cannot
explain how to get access to this video
in the game as it was due to an error
that I was able to see this I don't even
have time to explain why I don't have
time to explain the dark below DLC is
scheduled for release on December 9th
and will contain new story missions a
higher level cap of 32 and new exotic
weapons and armor we've been keeping a
close eye on Destiny here at Gamespot
check out our new breakdown of the iron
banner mode which is live now in The
Crucible and be sure to check out
gamespot.com newws for all the latest up
States as the release of the dark below
draws
closer